c'est une rupture difficile à encaisser
comme le barrage me retient plus l'eau
la rivière la lanterne s'est écoulée
sans obstacle dans la saône 140 employés
n'ont pas pu venir travailler ce matin
lusine ne peut plus puiser d'eau
pourtant essentiel à son activité
on appelle points entre les entreprises
donc si je l'autorisation du
propriétaire de passionnant son père
soit battu le japon est l'un des dégâts
liés aux intempéries
c'est un barrage qui est du siècle
précédent largement on surveille mais
j'allais dire papa tous les matins et
forcément il subit aussi les outrages du
temps et il subit aussi les multiples
cru qu'on connaît maintenant et qu'on ne
connaissait pas avant ça c'est clair que
j'allais dire les larges césar faire
fonctionner l'usiné a besoin de 250
mille litres d'eau par heure impossible
donc d'ouvrir dans ces conditions
normalement l'eau se situe oui au dessus
de cette poutre on a perdu très
rapidement à peu près 80 centimètres
d'elle la rupture du barrage hier soir
vers 18h fallait qu'on arrête les pompes
sinon on allait tout détruire donc voilà
donc la décision a été prise de passer
en chômage technique pour aujourd'hui
refroidir des matières et reims et des
équipements l'eau est indispensable dans
la production de fils de fer avec 50000
tonnes fabriquées chaque année la
fermeture de l'usiné n'arrange pas le
directeur on arrive à prendre certaines
commandes notamment sur ses équipements
l'a déjà pratiquement jusqu'en février
2022 donc
tout retard tout retard qui est pris est
perdu l'usiné compte réparer la digue
pendant la fermeture estivale
histoire de reprendre son activité d'ici
trois semaines